les royals ont voyagé lalala et la laddh
après tantine zaza et avec aujourd'hui
paniandy ce nouvel album
françoise weber qu'on appelle
affectueusement la diva du maloya
c'est à nouveau la une de l'actualité
musicale réunionnaise
rencontre avec une femme authentique qui
chantent dansent jouent du théâtre
soutient et encourage de jeunes talents
son parcours de paix de lausanne et
symbolise parfaitement des traditions
artistiques culturelles qui ne sont
proches mais disons que j'avais ça dans
la peau depuis tout petit je voulais
devenir chanteuse
et grâce à dieu approche de chanter dans
les églises que vaille à 50 avec mes
amis de la cour un jour j'ai écrit ma
première petite composition pour être
toujours ben choisissez le savon de
toilette d'aider des panneaux publicité
de se trouver ici et là
j'ai pris les paroles magiques de ses
plus voilà j'ai amené ce composé et puis
un jour tout en allant travailler chez
une grande dame à saint denis
madame reconnaissant le petit elle me
disais pourquoi tu chantes toujours en
français essaye d'écrire un séga avant
c'était la mode cible avant tout les
gens de mon âge et mes parents c'est là
que vous mettez accession séga mauricien
et là j'ai décrit comme armé comme tu m
bon et puis j'ai créé mon premier cd
après voilà tu peux écrire dans ces cas
c'est joli conte inuit bourg-la-reine
quand ils osent a senti une odeur que tu
me connais apple arrive dans dota défilé
comme ça donc j'avais peut-être dont des
cultures pas seulement pour les chansons
français parce que j'avais déjà écrit
pas mal de chansons phrasé c'est voir un
homme bon qui arrive au niveau du chant
ce que je croyais beaucoup que me
trouver les talents et puis a pris à la
scène
on m'a conseillé d'aller voir dicter
leur égard c'était vérité comme ça par
le micro à 160 c est ce que je vous
rappeler votre première scène
ah oui c'était à sa guise oui première
ses nerfs parce que je parle pas des
petits petits scène ici et là ça va mais
là problème avec le défunt rené noël le
carreau peut-être que tu as plairait à
rfo donc celui qui m'a permis de faire
mon match premières scènes on participe
à une émission
auteur compositeur et on m'a noté 5e et
les journalistes ont écrit françoise
guimbert 5e elle méritait mieux je ne
savais pas ce que pour la première fois
je monte un peu donc je savais pas
comment sur l'extrême le micro sur le
pied parce que j'aime bien changer avec
le micro à la main
il avait un public mousse avec comme je
vis jacques on fire les compagnies qui
avaient déjà et l'effet sensationnel
donc c'était vraiment fort quelqu'un
d'autre me plaise à dieu moi j'ai dansé
j'ai chanté et j'ai vu que j'étais
captivé les gens parce que j'en ris on
danse et on était content rires parce
que dans mes compositions et les
créations il ya aussi le lourd auteur
compositeur interprète vous êtes une
artiste complète
je veux dire on a beau est auteur
compositeur pas je parle pour moi l'un
si je ressentais pas ce que je fais je
crois que je repars je n'aurais pas aimé
et là quand je suis sur scène je prends
mon pied là tous les coups et là je vais
dire oui je suis auteur compositeur
quand vous écrivez vos chansons vous
qu'est ce que vous retenez qu'est ce qui
vous inspire ce qui m'inspire
d'abord il faut que je la sens ce que je
suis en train d'écrire ce qui est de ma
tête ce que j'ai envie de sentir si je
ne sens pas j'arrête je ferai pas comme
en ce moment je suis en train d'écrire
mon lit bagnoli à chaque fois que je
suis psp je laisse le cahier là je
mangerai pour ne pas écrire des bêtises
c'est comme ça vous avez en ce moment à
que de porter le maloya hors du
département
est ce qu'elle est projet en ce sens oui
cet album et c'est pour un le dernier
album paniandy est fait pour c'est dans
l'idée de christophe david avoir
travaillé dans ce sens par le maloya
loin
donc là on a un projet pour aller
en france un peu partout dans l'europe
et et puis pour on est déjà programmée
pour 2003 à la tasmanie
donc j'ai un master 21 mai donc il n'y a
pas de problème bientôt y'aura gts la
cedh en charge et ce sera votre premier
déplacement hors du département
oui oui je dis malheureusement à mon âge
j'ai fait mon premier voyage que cette
année c'est fabuleux
c'est fabuleux baisse et le rsa ce
fameux bandit qui est apprécié par hydro
major à fond c'est super bien reçu mon
talent ou bien dans une cohue fanal lui
fait goutali montaleau péter à trame au
béal telle mécanique est un très mauvais
at elle dit mon nom me savent haqqani
qui me monte pas grandie pagnol qui
n'étaient pas là où on pose la question
de mon camion 10 et la oumma à passer
mes vacances dans les hautes sphères lui
dit oui d'aller au bois pas l'eau là où
ce bon vivant j'avais peut-être si c'est
un jeu mis sur ma cousine et
quotas pour passer des vacances vacances
que six salles il avait le lez le bye
bye mais le plaisir que d'aller
l'arrivée pour moi sacré chez après
manger goya bhl sauter cracked famine et
puis le champ de cannes les chants des
oiseaux chantent en bonis on a là un
éleveur de la nature formidable c'est
pourquoi est-ce qu'on peut dire que le
panier mais alors que votre enfance oui
évoque mon enfance ma jeunesse même
c'est pourquoi je chante tram-train
bombay at elle gagné qui à droite mobile
at-elle dit momo remis ça va paniquer
mimoun paniandy donc c'est pourquoi j'ai
voulu donner un petit ont à nouveau à
tous de bons souvenirs que j'ai dans la
tête
jouer il ya quelques années je lui
plaisais de faire du théâtre avec
l'autre côté l'entourage alex hilton
production saint denis c'était vraiment
très belles pièces
est-ce que ça fait simplement qu'après
moi j'ai monté ma pièce aussi avec les
jeunes alors ne la mettent à nous amuser
les gens aussi donc j'adore le théâtre
je crois que c'est ça je suis mannequin
comédienne
c'est donc l'armée avait les gens donc
après luc m'a appelé pour jouer la
dernière personne prochaine fois que je
pars pu aller même avec un homme dalons
théâtre le poche pas pu aller dans ces
domaines mais j'adore assez bien le dire
je reviendrai un jour cinq ans avec
samantha le ternissement beaucoup et
j'adore chanter mais j'adore aussi par
pas jouer mais j'avais monté tu vois pas
ce que j'écris la piège mieux que soi
même le décor moi même joie et et ça ça
me manque je veux dire on fait ça on
vous se nomme la diva du maloya
mais c'est une diva au grand coeur aussi
puisque je nageais de cesse d'aider vos
proches qui veulent se faire un nom dans
la musique locale pour au ski et aider
mon prochain
nelly gens qui voudraient venir chanter
ou veulent faire connaître la zone oui
ma porte est ouverte n'est pas à tout le
monde mais je fais un choix re je vois
si c'est possible travailler avec ce
jeune là bas avec jean avec jean monnet
j'en ai dit je relaie ce possible on a
fait un bon bout de chemin
d'ailleurs n'arrête pas ils ont toujours
besoin de moi quand je conseille moi
j'ai besoin deux principaux comme je
croyais pas si j'avais besoin pour
discuter avec quelque chose dont on
saura si la cause pour moi même baba
moment-même plairait d'y revenir au père
au zaman rotana
rosana mon chéri la joya son troisième
cd il est en train de travailler sur son
troisième cd est d'accord il est content
de danser avec sa fille et avec ses
choristes
donc il va aller loin il a une belle
voix 1 il était loin donc jean les
parties pour trente ans qu'on voit très
important pour ces jeunes là d'être
encouragée par quelqu'un qui connaît
déjà le milieu puis sa mère il appuie il
a pris racine
chez moi
c'est pourquoi il avait même bien vous
veniez en pourparlers pour prendre une
décision pour voir si c'est bien ce qui
fait bonne composition me demande me
fais couper pour voir si c'est bon et ça
c'est important pour lui et pour moi
aussi parce que ce ce qui fait que je
suis content de l'avoir côtoyé je me dis
je lui apporter quelque chose
bien sûr vous occupez de gens mais il ya
aussi jean rené vihear et jean-rené
depuis 2000 2001 il a travaillé sur des
textes à lui et j'ai revu un peu de
tests comme j'ai dit tout à l'heure vers
l'iss en créole
écrit quelques couplets pour lui et
berna ou à l'abondance on donne paquet
bientôt on va danser sur son cd ça vous
arrive souvent d'être corée ce soit des
chansons
oui j'ai fait avec géant je fais aussi
avec l'axé mais un look de jeune auteur
compositeur bénédictins et bientôt je
vais faire avec un autre jeune à sa
baignoire
donc il n'ya pas de problème je suis
toujours présent et là je vais
travailler avec le groupe le groupe arc
en ciel qui vaut un groupe
d'associations fonker mange que le corps
à corps est cédé pour la fête de pâques
donc on va s'y mettre là où travaillent
c'est un grand plaisir pour moi de
travailler avec les chefs c'est pour une
bonne cause ma religion ça mais vous
êtes instrumentistes c'est ça vous
arrive de toucher un petit peu aux
instruments et je touche est également
mais la même terre impénitent je fais un
peu de piano d'ailleurs j'apprends les
jeunes aussi je fais aussi là je connais
bien je fais mon rôle je mangeais des
techniques kayak est justement appelé
sauf de batteries d'avoir un pro mais il
faut la scène moi pourquoi vous avez une
formation musicale de faire une seule
musique
oui et puis il faut avoir un que ça dans
le sang d'accord quand j'allais au sens
où je savais déjà à jouer le caillou ce
n'est pas juif ikg et encore moins le
rouleur c'est bien d'être là de loges il
m'a appris à jouer heures indemnisables
saoudite aux tâches tout moment et
arrive la cage mal à fait pareil tantôt
moments de leur idylle à quoi françois
c'est ce que vous avez un petit message
à délivrer toujours sur le monde musical
à la réunion et bien que
la musique l'art et pas de progresser
oui il faut aller toujours dans ce sens
ça je trouve l'année 2010 est une bonne
cuvée
oui et que ça continue a fait des bons
textes et bonne musique et que le manuel
s'égaillent ça va loin
mon